Good afternoon. A very warm welcome
to our session here. I'm not Jakob Kata. I wish I were, but I'm not.
Jakob could not make it
today with some of the
logistic challenges coming from Germany to here.
So
we are very fortunate, however, that he was able to send his recorded talk.
So we'll get there in a second. I'm George Visilo.
I'm the Chief AI for Science Innovation at AstraZeneca, and I'm going to
pass here to my impromptu co-chair.
Hi. Very nice to meet all of you. T. Rubihani from Recursion Pharmaceuticals,
VP of Translational Strategy.
So it's
an immense pleasure to have all of you here during lunchtime today
because we are witnessing
a new era of translational research, clinical development
across academia and biopharm.
It is happening. It's a reality, and I think here we will have the
opportunity of discussing how
the
research is evolving today, how the future looks like,
and what it is that we need to do to get to the
future that we're all talking about.
Because AI is no longer the future, it's happening today.
So without any further ado, let's move to the first talk,
that's by Professor Jakob Kata.
He is the
Chair of Clinical AI at University of Dresden
in Germany, and he also has a laboratory at
University of Heidelberg in Germany as well.
He has been a leader
in terms of the development of
AI-driven biomarkers in oncology,
and he has also developed a number of frontier
solutions in the agentic space, actually helping
us reimagine tumor boards from first principles
through the lens of AI, not with AI. It's extremely exciting.
So, I'm going to ask our technical team here to
play the video now. Let's hope it works. Fingers crossed.
Hello and welcome. My name is Jakob Kata.
I'm Professor of Clinical Artificial Intelligence in Dresden and
Heidelberg in Germany. My flight was canceled.
I'm late to the conference, so I have to pre-record this.
Very sorry, but I will be there for the Sunday sessions and Monday
sessions. Please get in touch. And now I
want to share my slides and share with you my talk about multimodal
and agentic AI in biomarker discovery.
Here are my disclosures.
Let's look at how the field of AI developed in the last 20
years. It all started with what we now call classical machine learning
methods, where you train machine learning models to, for example, work with
tabular data or with pre-extracted features from images to solve
tasks such as prediction, prognostication, classification,
et cetera.
But,
of course, as we all know, these methods were not sufficient for the
complexity of data we face in cancer research,
specifically image data, for example, histopathology
images. So the field was completely changed in the 2010s when
deep learning came along, and we were able to train deep learning models
on large image datasets or other complex datasets
for tasks such as classification, object
segmentation, many others.
In the 2020s, in the last couple of years, the field has
been changed again by the advent of foundation models.
These are big models that you train once with self-supervised learning
on a large heterogeneous image cohort or
dataset, and then you can use them and fine-tune
them or apply them to additional
downstream tasks. And typically, if you do this two-step approach, then you
don't need as much data for the downstream tasks, and you can solve them
much better. Another type of foundation models is, of course, large
language models. These are just big foundation models that have been trained
on natural language, so they can be used in natural language processing, but
they have also obtained a generalist world
knowledge and of course, are the basis for all the chatbots, ChatGPT, and
everything that everybody's using.
I think the most interesting part of these large language models is that
they have enabled the technology of AI agents, where you
take a large language model and you connect it to other tools so that it can
solve complex tasks. Here, I'm going to show you
a few examples how all of this comes together, how we can
use deep learning to develop multimodal or unimodal
biomarkers, and how we can then use AI agents
to develop them much faster.
First of all, let's speak about the biomarkers.
And I want to just share this terminology that we have
developed in our professional society, ESMO, European Society of Medical
Oncology last year, and this has been published as a guideline.
We've looked at the entire field of
AI in cancer research and oncology, looked at the
publications, looked at the products that are out there.
And there's three classes of AI-based
biomarkers, where AI is being used to derive
properties of tumors that help us make better treatment decisions.
Class A is using AI for biomarker quantification, and
this is very simple because here what you're doing is you're just
recapitulating the human workflow. Okay?
So imagine a PD-L1 stained
immunohistochemistryslide in
lung cancer. Normally, a human would
read this and would score the PD-L1 staining intensity.
Now you can train AI systems to do the same thing, obviously with
potentially much better reproducibility and also
faster turnaround, et cetera. And many of these Class A
biomarkers are already on the market.
Class B would be the use of AI to indirectly
measure existing biomarkers. For example, using
pathology slides to make inferences
about genetic alterations. There's now a lot of
research available and also commercially approved products whereby you
can predict microsatellite instability in colorectal cancer from
pathology slides, EGFR mutations
in lung cancer,
gene fusions, many other mutations, tumor
mutational burden, and many of these can be inferred just
from the pathology images. This is a Class B biomarker.
There's also other works that have shown that you can predict IDH
mutational status from brain imaging in
glioma
patients. So there's a lot of work here.
These biomarkers are typically not perfect, but good enough to be useful as
pre-screening tests. Class C biomarkers are entirely new
biomarkers where we train, for example, on radiology images, pathology
images, genomic data,
one of these, or all of these, or any combinations of these to
predict treatment outcomes directly.
For example, you can train an AI model to predict resist
response based on these baseline images, or you can train an
AI model to predict survival and/or adjuvant
treatment
efficacy, et cetera. You can predict clinical endpoints directly, and this
would be a Class C biomarker. If you're interested, if you're
working in this field, this has been published last year in "Annual of Oncology"
and
we think that this could be a scaffold to talk about these AI
biomarkers. Now, what does it have to do with agents?
I've already mentioned initially that large language models, of course, everybody
knows large language models that can be used as chatbots.
They can also be enriched with additional context.
For example, medical guidelines or your personal
documents that the chatbot can access.
But if you generalize this more, what you get is an agent.
Agents are large language models that can interact with any other
software or any other tool to
perform additional actions that they cannot perform natively.
For example, to interact with a web browser or a command line
interface. And then you can build them also in a way that they
iterate and perform multi-step
problem-solving. Let me introduce some
terminology here. The AI model itself, the large language
model, has weights. It's just
a bunch of weights with the architecture, and this is the
actual model. It has been trained
once and then you use it. You can place this in
harness, which would allow for example, computer use,
browser use, terminal use, et cetera, and then you can package this harness
in apps that people use. There's just some
examples here. This is of course, already a bit outdated, but I think it's
important to get this terminology right.
And how does this apply to
drug development, biomarker development?
Well, it applies because a
lot of what we do in biomarker development, drug development
is just a human using a computer, right?
In a very simplified way, it's a human researcher looking at
experimental data, making a hypothesis, writing code,
running code, debugging code, making presentations, et cetera.
All of these steps can be performed in principle by
an AI agent. Now, probably today's
agents are not ready to do this completely autonomously, right?
But again,
what we are seeing right now is that the LLM-based AI agents that
are available right now already automate part of
this pipeline. And ultimately, I think it's safe to say
that anything a human does with a computer can ultimately be
automated.
Let me show you some examples. We've built these agents in our
research group mainly for clinical
applications. So these are
very relevant, of course also for biomarker development and
biomarker application.
One example is this work where we built a tumor board agent.
You have a large language model. You give it access to a patient case, all the
radiology, all the pathology images, all the genomic data that
the patient has, access to a database of clinicaltrials.gov, et
cetera, and then the agent does stepwise
reasoning and uses tools to analyze all these data and comes up
with a recommendation. We validated this obviously against
human experts and found a very good performance.
We've also developed autonomous agents, and this is unpublished, should
come out soon, where we have agents that can look
at patient cases and then not just piece all the
diagnostic information together, but also take actions in that they,
for example, can request additional imaging, request
procedures, request laboratory tests, and then you can
basically, we again benchmark this against human doctors, so you can basically
automate the entire treatment journey in this
scenario.So how does this relate not just to
biomarker application, but also to the development of biomarkers?
Well, as I said, anything a human developer does with a
computer can ultimately be done with an agent.
Right now, there's different components of this that can be
done with agents. Many people are using this.
In my lab everybody's using this. In many other labs, in
industry, everybody's using agents,
specifically coding agents, software development agents such as Claude Code
or Codex are, of course, very powerful.
And
they are generalist agents, general purpose agents that
are also very good at bioinformatics
tasks and research tasks and biomarker development tasks.
And in fact, many people are using them for this purpose.
This is just an example, asking Claude Code to
do a QC on genetic data.
It's probably not perfect, but it can be
done.
Of course, I have no conflict of interest here, but there is many
companies out there that are developing this, basically domain
specific agents. And now the question is,
and I think that's an unresolved question, what is really the
secret sauce? What makes a drug development agent, what
makes a biomarker development agent unique, right?
Can you just use Claude Code or do you need more specific
scaffolding? I think the answer is
evolving, right? For as many cases, generalist agents are very good.
For other cases, you might need specific agents.
Another example where I don't have
any conflict of interest, right?
One of the trailblazers in this field, one of the pioneers was,
of course, Jure Leskovec and his group's paper,
Bi omni, and their agentic
applications in biomedicine. Some of these you can
reproduce nowadays with Claude Code.
Some of these you cannot because they require specific tooling that
is embedded. So the field is evolving super fast.
What I think is one of the most important scientific questions is
how to evaluate agents. I really like and highly
recommend this
Pokemon
evaluation of agents where you can basically take
large language models and give them a harness that lets them
play Pokemon Red in this case. And then you can
see how these agents solve the problems, how they basically
succeed in solving tasks iteratively, how they advance through
the
game, through the different milestones in the game.
This example is of course highly outdated, but you can see that each of these
lines is one large language model in an agent harness playing
Pokemon. And you can see that there's differences in how they advance
through the game. And this is a benchmark.
This is a classical agent benchmark where you test the capabilities of these agents
for multi-step problem solving. And I think these are the types
of benchmarks that we need. We cannot just like previously in AI,
have one system that produces one output.
We compare it with the gold standard, and then we have our performance.
No, we have to look at the procedures that the tool calls
benchmarking is now--
Benchmarking of agents is now becoming very complex, and we
still need to develop the conceptual frameworks for this.
And I think if we can
formulate
biomedical research, biomarker development
as we can formulate
games such as Pokemon Red, then we will make advancements in providing
good benchmarks for agents.
I want to close with one
warning slide. Agents are of course--
any AI systems and agents in particular are of course
susceptible to many pitfalls. There's of course
hallucinations, many other potential problems.
We are very interested in
attacks on agents, attacks on
AI systems, for example, prompt injection attacks whereby
a user that interacts with an agent can hide
prompts in the input data, even in images, even
like invisible texts and images. And of course, there are many
efforts ongoing to harden large language models and other AI
systems and agentic systems against these attacks.
But there is no universal cure here, and it's still
possible deliberately or accidentally
to perform prompt injections. For example, when pathologists
write with a pen on a slide, PT3,
then a lazy agent will typically just look at
the text and not the image and become confused, right?
We've done these two studies.
Dr. Fersch who led this study on the right-hand side, he's also
going to give a talk here in another session.
So if you're interested, please reach out to him.
And with that, I want to say thank you for your attention.
I hope that this was interesting. Please reach out.
Here's my email address. Again,
I will arrive a bit later and there's a session tomorrow.
There's a plenary session on Monday at 8:00 a.m. Thank you very much.
Thank you very much to the other speakers and see you there.
One of the benefits of technology.
And actually,
before we move to the questions here in the room-
Hello and welcome.
Just because I praise technology, we have a glitch.
Anyhow,
so there was a question online already that what
are
The AUCs, the sensitivity and specificity values
associated with Class 3 biomarkers.
And I had the opportunity of actually asking Jacob as he flies here.
So his answer was that this is an excellent question and not an
easy one.
That there's no universal cutoff.
Actually, in this context of the
Class 3 biomarkers or Class C here,
what's imperative is that there is clinical utility and
that validation in adequate data sets is performed.
One important point, in particular, when we move to these biomarkers for which
there is no gold standard that we can perform directly an
analytical validation, is that we
may not need full explainability of the model.
What we need is validation in multiple data sets that are
fit for purpose. Imagine the levels of evidence that
we require for clinical utility
being also applied to this framework of biomarkers driven by
AI. Just because we are using really cutting-edge technology
does not give us poetic license to bypass the levels of evidence that are
required and sufficient for us to deliver something in the clinic that
is transformational.
Do we have any questions in the room?
Tiru and I will try to fill them in the absence of Jacob.
One, two, three. So thank you so much.
So we move to the next talk ahead of schedule. Can you believe it?
Efficiency. Let's do it. So I
have an immense pleasure here to invite Tirup
Behanie, my impromptu co-chair today.
She's the VP for Translational Strategy at Recursion, and
it's a company that actually is doing drug discovery and clinical
development through AI first principles.
Tirup, it's such a pleasure to have you with us today.
I look forward to your talk.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon, everyone. Thank you for being here, and thank you to the
ACR organizers for inviting Recursion to be a part of
this very important discussion. As my co-chair has
said,
it's very topical for our industry, and I'm excited to be a part of it.
Today what I was hoping to do is to walk through a couple of
examples of our clinical stage programs that
really highlight how Recursion is using AI in
practice to inform everyday decisions across the
R&D continuum. So from biology through to chemistry through
to the clinic.
So first, a quick introduction on Recursion Pharmaceuticals.
We are a novel medicines company. We are aiming
to produce better molecules, more differentiated
molecules, for more meaningful outcomes for patients.
And we're using AI, as I mentioned, across the R&D continuum
to help us get there.
We have proprietary multimodal data at industrial scale.
We've designed purpose-built models with
the ability to answer key biological, chemical, and clinical
questions. And importantly, we've built bilingual teams,
so both scientists that are fluent in AI, as well as
AI engineers that are fluent in science.
And together, these teams can create biological
insights that we can translate then into clinical strategies
and eventually execution, and hopefully we can show meaningful outcomes for
patients.
But the real differentiation for Recursion is how it all comes together.
Because we believe that we're one of the few AI-native companies that
has end-to-end operations, so really applying
AI, again, across the R&D continuum.
And we believe that's because it's important not only
to improve the decisions that we make in
one area of R&D, but really across the entire value chain.
So here I'm introducing our Recursion platform, the Recursion
OS. And it really is sort of broken up into three distinct
pieces.
In the first piece, the left-hand side, you'll see that
we can go from biology to insight. Here's
where we can use our platform to really identify causal disease
mechanisms. And what this does is it allows us to identify novel
targets and the associated diseases for
those targets.
Then in the middle, we have our precision design part of our platform.
So here's where we can really optimize our chemical synthesis
and produce molecules that have differentiated properties,
optimized properties, and those that will really help us achieve the
therapeutic outcomes and the therapeutic indices that we're really going for.
And then on the right-hand side, you can see we go from molecule to patient.
So this is our clin tech platform. Here's where we can
identify the right patient using causal modeling.
We use RWD analyses to help
contextualize our trial data,
and we also are able to run our trials more efficiently by using
AI-informed enrollment.
The goal, of course, across this entire platform is to be able to not
only improve our chance of success, but also reduce the time
and the money that's typically used for traditional R&D processes.
So what this has led to is we're very proud of our wholly owned
pipeline at Recursion. We have five clinical stage assets
and a couple of programs coming behind those clinical stage assets.
And what really differentiates each one of these programs is that
they've been informed by a specific
insight or specific set of insights that have come from our platform.
We are very encouraged by our clinical programs and the momentum that we have
and again, the number of programs that we have coming behind those.We believe that
they have first-in-class and best-in-class potential.
And again, in the next couple of slides, I'm going to show you
examples of three different programs and how we've applied AI in
practice across these
examples.
So one thing to note is that we don't apply our platform
uniformly across all of our programs.
Instead, we use specific parts of our platform to
really hone in on key challenges and answer key problems within
each program.
So on the left-hand side of this slide, you're seeing our platform again, just in a
slightly different format. You've got the biology to insight piece, the
precision design piece, and the clin tech piece.
And each one of these components,
you can see how they're being used across our programs on the top.
So for today, I'm going to focus on three pieces of our pipeline,
the REC-1245 program, which is an RBM39
degrader,
the REC-617 program, which is a CDK7 inhibitor,
and the REC-4881 molecule, which is a MEK1/2 inhibitor for the
potential treatment of a rare orphan precancerous disease called
FAP.
So first, let's get into RBM39 and the REC-1245 program.
As I mentioned, we don't use every part of our platform for every single
program. But what's great about REC-1245 is this program's
a great example of how we've used our phenomaps
and biological insights to really identify a novel therapeutic
target.
So back in 2021, using genome scale
phenomapping, which are basically our maps of biology, what
we uncovered is a really important relationship.
We found that RBM39 was actually a functional analog of
CDK12,
and this is an already well-established oncology target.
So what we were then able to do is profile a number of
compounds in our phenomap to show
functional
biology and phenocopying of the CDK12 protein.
We did this rapidly, and we were able to optimize degraders and
land on our lead candidate with only 200 molecules
synthesized, and it went from target identification to
IND-enabling studies in just under 18 months.
So very proud of how fast we were able to do this.
Again,
all of this in an effort to improve our clinical success, but also reducing the
time and money that traditional R&D processes take.
On the next slide, we've expanded the map that I showed you on the previous slide.
In the middle is the smaller portion of the map that I showed on the previous
slide, showing the RBM39 and CDK12
functional relationship. But if you zoom out, what you see is
that there's also a relationship with DNA damage repair,
epigenetic regulation, transcription, cell cycle control,
and of course, all of this is very consistent with RBM39
biology. So this really validates our phenomap to be able to
uncover the actual biology that's taking place.
So very quickly, mechanistically, RBM39 is a protein that
regulates splicing fidelity. So when you actually degrade this
protein, what you end up getting is widespread splicing
defects. You can imagine then that tumors that
have global genomic instability, high replication
stress, or have DNA damage repair defects
would be quite susceptible to RBM39 degradation.
And so that's what we went forward with, and the hypothesis we tried to
confirm here.
So one evidence of genomic instability
are tumors that have high MSI high status, so
microsatellite instability. And what we're showing here is that in a
model of ovarian cancer that has MSI high status,
you can see dose-dependent degradation of the RBM39 protein.
And this actually translates in vivo, and you can see monotherapy activity
of REC-1245 in the model that has microsatellite
instability.
We took this one step further and confirmed this in a number of other models.
On the left-hand side is another ovarian model that has MSI
high status. This model also happens to have DDR defects,
again,
going along with the biology we showed before.
And then when we profiled not only additional MSI high
models but compared these to MSS models, so those with more
stable genomes, you could see that there was a trend that
those models that had higher global genomic
instability were more sensitive to REC-1245 than
those that had more stable genomes.
All of this led to our clinical study design and our eligible population.
We have an ongoing Phase 1/2 monotherapy study called the
DAHLIA study.
And what we've
done with this study design is allowed patients that have tumor types
that naturally have high levels of genomic instability, as
well as biomarker-enriched populations of patients with tumors that
have high MSI status.
We're continuing dose escalation right now, and we will be hoping to
share a preliminary safety and PK update in the first half of this year.
But what we really wanted to highlight is that RBM39 and the REC-1245
program is a great example of how we could take a novel
biological insight and actually turn it into
a drug program, and that led us to a translational
hypothesis and eventually our patient selection and clinical study
design.
Next, we have the REC-617 program.
This is a CDK7 inhibitor. For this
program, we leveraged two parts of the platform, the precision design
piece of the platform, where we really optimized this molecule to
have properties that we were looking for to increase the therapeutic
index.Now, it took us only
136 molecules to come up with our lead candidate, and we did this
in under 12 months. Again, really highlighting the speed and efficiency
with which we can do this type of work.
Today, I'm going to focus more so on the right-hand side and how we got to
the decision to prioritize ovarian cancer as our
indication in our first in-human trial.
So again, for this program,
there are a number of biological insights, the
generative AI and active learning that we did to get to a
lead candidate and use our precision design capabilities.
We have our in vivo data that I'll show you on the next slide, but really, again, I
want to focus on some of the clinical data and the causal modeling we did
to identify ovarian cancer as a sensitive population.
So here on the left, you're seeing an in vitro ovarian cell line
that has sensitivity to REC-617. This is
dose-dependent
cell growth inhibition, and this translates into the in vivo model
where you see all three doses of REC-617 as a
monotherapy produce not only significant tumor growth
inhibition, but actually tumor regressions in all three doses.
Based on some causal inference and multi-omic and clinical
data, what we were really able to show is the relationship
between CDK7 and a vulnerability in ovarian cancer.
So on the right-hand side, what you're looking at are thousands of patient
records that we mined and analyzed to show that
patients with high CDK7 in their tumors had lower
overall
survival and poor prognosis versus those patients that had
low CDK7 expression. And again, this helped us
establish more of a causal relationship for CDK7 in ovarian
cancer versus just a correlative one.
And I bring this up because a number of other CDK7 programs are
actually going into a different indication.
And so we followed our data, followed our AI-enabled
insights to really prioritize ovarian cancer as a
differentiated indication for this molecule.
Importantly, in our dose escalation, we saw that we had a
PR in a patient that had ovarian cancer.
Again, this really just confirms our hypothesis that ovarian cancer
patients would be sensitive to a CDK7 inhibitor.
Our Phase 1/2 trial is ongoing. It's called ELUCIDATE.
We've reached MTD.
We're exploring alternative dosing schedules, and we've started
our combination cohorts as well. We look forward to sharing an update on all
of this in 2027.
The final program I'll turn to is the REC-4881
program or MEK1/2 for the potential treatment of
familial adenomatous polyposis, or FAP.
So this program actually came out of an insight from one of the
earliest versions of our platform.
And what the insight actually showed us is that we could take a
known mechanism inhibiting MEK1/2 and actually
repurpose it for a completely new indication in which this mechanism has
never been studied before clinically.
Currently, we have an ongoing trial, and we're using our clin tech part of
our platform to really use our real-world
evidence analyses to contextualize this data, which is super important
because this is a rare disease.
So a little bit of background here on FAP.
This is a disease that's caused by the loss of function in a gene
called APC.
And when you lose APC function,
patients with FAP will develop hundreds to thousands of
polyps in their colon and rectum. And if they're left
untreated, nearly 100% of these patients are at
risk of developing colorectal cancer.
About 50,000 patients in the US and EU5 have
FAP.
And unfortunately, these patients undergo a lifetime of
endoscopic surveillance, frequent excisional interventions,
and life-altering surgeries, and all of this leads to very poor
quality of life, morbidity, and poor long-term
outcomes for these patients. So really highlighting the unmet need
for this group of patients.
So within the rare disease space, natural history data is
very important in order to be able to contextualize the data that
you're getting from clinical trial results.
Unfortunately, for FAP, there's little known about the disease outside
of clinical trials. And so our clin tech team
aimed to fill this gap by building a-- I'm sorry, I
missed a slide. Let me first tell you about how we discovered 4881.
So REC-4881 came out of a phenotypic discovery
map, essentially where we knocked out APC,
and we were able to show that after profiling thousands of compounds, that
4881 was able to
produce a rescue effect in these cells.
So it converted a disease state cell into a healthy state
cell. Now we'll move to the natural
history part.
So for rare disease, again, in order to contextualize your clinical data, natural
history data is very, very important because there is just not a lot of
ability to often do controlled trials
and understand what your trial results mean.
Unfortunately for FAP, a lot of quantified data doesn't exist outside of clinical
trials. And so this is where our clin tech team aimed
to fill that gap. So they created a custom
LLM analysis of 1,000 US FAP
patients using over 250,000 US physician
notes in order to be able to understand and
contextualize the natural progression of polyp
burdenHere you can see that
we did an additional follow-up with the Amsterdam University Medical
Center and used their largest and longest
running FAP registry to additionally contextualize
our results coming from our clinical trial.
This registry actually has over 20 years of
follow-up for about 200 patients.
And so what this allowed us to do was really understand at scale for the
first time how polyp burden progresses in these patients.
And you'll notice that 87% of untreated FAP
patients had annual polyp
burden increase shown in this waterfall plot here, and an
average of 60% polyp burden increase annually.
I want you to keep this graph in mind as I move to the next slide because it's
really going to show you the difference between an untreated population and our
trial results coming out of our phase one, two Tipelo trial.
So here you see the increase in polyp burden.
However, when we look at our trial data, so these are FAP patients
treated with 12 weeks of 4881 therapy.
And you can see after just 12 weeks of therapy, a reduction in polyp
size, not an increase, compared to the natural history data.
75% of the patients responded, and the overall
median polyp burden reduction was 43%.
Importantly, the safety profile was consistent with MEK1/2 inhibitors and this
class of compounds, and the majority of the adverse
events were grade one/two.
What's really interesting is what's coming up on the next slide.
So not only did we see this polyp reduction at 12 weeks, but
we saw that there's actually durable polyp
reduction response in these patients.
So this is a graph showing the polyp burden after
being off therapy for 12 weeks, and you can see that
82% of the patients remained responders and that the
polyp burden reduction remained at 53%.
So this is very exciting for the Recursion team.
This is the first time we've shown clinical validation of our
platform insight and really showing the full arc of how you can
go from a biological
insight all the way to clinical validation.
And I think what's very, very interesting about this program, again, was the
ability for us to take our map and actually come up with a
novel indication for a MEK1/2 inhibitor that has never been
uncovered before.
So hopefully I've shown you today the different ways in which
Recursion and the way our industry can use AI across the
R&D continuum. We believe that it's really important to make sure
that we're answering key questions all along the way from the biology
standpoint, making sure that we're
identifying novel targets. From a chemistry standpoint,
using AI to really precision design medicines that are differentiated
and optimized, and then in the clinical space to really use
AI
for
selecting the right patients as well as designing your trials
in a way that will hopefully make them be as successful as possible.
We have a couple of additional things that we're trying to do.
Recursion is always innovating. One thing that
we're doing is
building something called Cell Neighbor.
So both of these things on this slide are aimed at really trying to close the
translational gap that exists. So for Cell Neighbor, what we do
is we actually map cell lines to patient tumor
biology. And what that allows us to do
by putting these both in the same transcriptional space, in practice,
it allows us to use models that are more translatable to patient
biology in the clinic, but it also allows us to avoid models
that do not translate into the clinic.
Again,
a very important piece of R&D in cancer research.
We're also building TxFM. This is a state-of-the-art
transcriptomics foundation model.
The goal here is to really bridge the gap between lab perturbations and patient
biology. We're very excited about this.
It's early days, but we believe that it has widespread applications that
will be able to use TxFM across target identification,
mechanistic understanding of our molecules, and as well as patient
selection. I'll just highlight that our Cell Neighbor will be
shown at AACR on Monday. There's a poster session from 9:00 to
12:00, so I highly encourage you to check that out, and the
TxFM foundational model will be shown at a
conference next week.
In closing, I just want to again reiterate our true belief
that
applying AI across the R&D continuum is critically
important to make sure that we're driving
informed decisions at every step of the process in order to increase our
chance of success and to reduce time and cost.
And thank you again.
Thank you
so much, Jeroo, for the fantastic presentation and
for showing us how you can deploy
AI solutions in a way that guides your,
let's say, drug discovery and clinical development in
such a transformational way. I have one quick question before
we open here too for questions that we have already
by the microphone. So
for CDK7, you made a really important point that
others are pursuing different indications, and you went into
that particular indication because of the insights that you are deriving through
your AI approaches and the new models that you have built.
Could you just elaborate a bit more as to how did you get yourself
comfortable enough to challenge the current status quo and to
venture into a completely different area?
Yeah.I think it was really a data-informed decision.
So we had the in vitro and in vivo preclinical proof of concept.
But I think really having thousands of patient data sets from
Tempus that shows that causal relationship
really drove that decision at the end of the day and helped us prioritize.
It also helped that we saw a partial response in our ovarian cancer
patient. We allowed advanced solid tumors in our dose escalation
study. But it was the ovarian cancer patient that had the partial response.
So that further validated and really made us
feel confident in that decision.
So just to test my understanding, it was both the
mechanistic explainability together with the
additional reasons you believe based on validation.
That's right.
It's a combination of the two. Yeah. Microphone starting here on the left.
Please identify yourself and then ask the question. Thank you.
Hello. Oh, excellent. It works.
Dr. Behani, thank you so very much. That is a wonderful presentation.
I have a question on the Recursion race.
It's clear that the link through across the entire value
chain is substantial.
My question is around the benchmark.
How many molecules
and mechanistic analyses actually link through to IND, and what's the
baseline?
That's a really good question. You mean across our pipeline?
That's correct.
How many go from left to right all the way through our platform?
Mm-hmm.
Again,
we don't use our platform uniformly across programs, and you may know that
Recursion also had a business combination with a company called
Exscientia
that also brought a couple of molecules into our pipeline.
They had their own precision design platform that then got
incorporated into our overall platform.
So again, not all of the molecules go from left
to right
all the way through. But the important piece, I think, is making sure that we're
using the right pieces of our platform to answer
the specific challenges of each program that we have.
Thank you so much.
So here on the microphone on the right.
Please identify yourself and ask the question. Thank you.
Thank you. I'm Mila. I'm a biomarker scientist.
It's really exciting to say you already use the foundation
model for the drug development. I also have
question about CDK7 because CDK7,
it's in ovarian cancer, right? It's a
enzyme. So my question is, are you using
CDK7 expression for patient selection
strategy or not? I'm also wondering about
the response difference between, for example,
CDK7 high expressers versus CDK7 low
expressers.
Yeah. As of now, we're not selecting patients based on CDK7
expression, but it's something we're continuously evaluating to
understand baseline profiles of all of our patients to really understand what our
patterns of response are going to be.
Okay, thank you.
Just to test my understanding,
how are you incorporating that then into your clinical development program?
So just continued analysis, interrogation of our
clinical patient data to see where the patterns of response will be.
Is that what you mean?
Yes. And what would trigger then a decision to go with a patient
selection strategy that is based on some type of
phenomics?
Yeah. It would have to be a large enough data set that really gives us
confidence. So what we're constantly doing at Recursion is
mixing our preclinical data, our clinical data, and our
computational abilities to continuously
interrogate and ask these types of questions as incoming
data is coming in from the clinic.
Right now nothing to share there, but that's a continued analysis that's happening
at Recursion.
Thank you so much. Microphone here on the left. Thank you.
Hi, this is Marta Milo, AstraZeneca, Oncology
Data Science and AI. Thank you very much for this
inspiring talk.
I'm intrigued about the causality and how you
use causality and AI in these particular case
studies that you showed us.
Could you elaborate more how you use causality, how you
evaluate it, and how you evaluate the uncertainty around causality?
Mm-hmm.
And how you use the data to model it.
So I'll use the CDK7 example here. So what
we did to make sure that it was truly causal in nature that the
CDK7 high expressers had overall worse prognosis,
is that all of the other variables in the analysis were actually fixed so
that we could really get gene-specific changes and
causality based on each gene that's changed.
That's about as much as I can say. I have my computational biology leader
here. I'm happy to answer more questions after the
talk.
Thank you.
Thank you. Microphone here on the right.
Hello, thank you for your presentation. I am Min Jung from Berkeley.
I'm from Witgen, which is developing virtual single-cell Gen
AI.
So thank you for
the presentation. It was very good to see all these kind of
assets that get into clinical trials.
Because maximizing AI
utility in the drug discovery is kind of very
difficult and was taking a long time.
So my first question is, how
are you evaluate the assets that
Recursion Therapeutics have done compared?
How fast do you get from the conventional
methodology using AI? And the second question
is,
so clinical data is especially very difficult
to acquire for a pharmaceutical company.
So how Recursion Therapeutics are
acquiring clinical data to get into clinical trials,
and are you using also the kind of data in the preclinical
trial in order to bridge the gap between in vitro and
in vivo?Okay. So your first
question-
Was
how faster are you getting?
How fast? Okay.
Is there a benchmark?
Thank you. It's been a long couple of days.
How fast? Well, hopefully, we showed you that with the CDK7 example,
we only had to synthesize around 136 molecules in under 12
months in order to land on our lead candidate.
This is again, because we're using closed loop, AI guided
design for our molecules that allows us to rapidly
optimize our chemical series. And then the same
thing for RBM39. We only needed about 200 molecules.
And we went from target identification to IND-enabling studies in about 18
months. So again, both examples of just how fast we can go
if we're using AI guided information.
Kira, just one question so that others who are not as familiar with
this. What are the industry benchmarks for the 136 and
200?
That is a good question. I think that's probably beyond my scope.
I've been with Recursion for just a couple of months now, but happy to entertain
those questions again. I have the full team here with me.
So let's continue that.
And the access to the data, the second question, how do you have access to clinical
data? That's a real challenge for pharma.
Yeah. So, the CDK7 example was
using Tempus data. So we had a relationship with Tempus to
evaluate thousands of patient data sets in order to really
come up with that causal relationship.
And then you saw for the 4881 trial, we really utilized that
Amsterdam UMC
registry again, because they have the longest and
largest registry for FAP
patients that have such long follow-up.
But in general, your question is a good one that where can we fill
in the gap with preclinical data? I think that's where, again, I
just reiterate that we have data coming from multiple sources, right?
We have preclinical data. Even for our clinical stage compounds, we're
continuously generating preclinical data to try and better understand our
molecules. We're getting clinical data from our ongoing trials,
and then we have these data sets like Tempus' data set or other registries that
allows us to put everything together to really have a large enough data
set to make some clear associations and
causal
relationships.
Thank you for this.
Thank you. Microphone here on the left.
Hi. I'm Catherine from University of Toronto.
My work involves CDK13 and splicing, so I'm really curious
about the RBM39 project at
Recursion. I'm curious about what's the
advantage of designing or looking for genes such as
RBM39, who mimics the loss of
function of CDK12 versus improving
the existing current degraders of
CDK12 and 13. And kind of to follow up on that,
did you observe any compensatory effect of
CDK12 and 13 when you inhibit
RBM39? Thank you.
Yeah, sure. So one thing I didn't talk about in the talk is that when
we saw this initial
relationship between RBM39 and CDK12,
what was key was that at that time, CDK12 inhibitors often were
coming with this liability that they would also hit CDK13.
And I think there was a belief that the inhibition of CDK13,
along with CDK12, was really causing toxicity
issues and causing really narrow therapeutic
windows. So that's why we were so excited when we saw this
relationship, that there was a way to have functional analog of
CDK12 by targeting RBM39, and that way
you don't have to inhibit CDK13 at the same time.
And the hope is that you'll have an improved therapeutic window.
As far as your compensatory mechanisms question, of course, for all of our
programs, we're continuously trying to understand where we have the greatest
benefit versus not, or greatest efficacy, and constantly
mining the data to understand if there are compensatory mechanisms that are
popping up that would reduce the effect of our drug.
Can't share any data on that right now, but that's something we're always doing.
Thank you.
Yeah, the microphone on the right.
Hi. Thanks for a great talk. Victor Chubuko from Freedom.
I'm curious if the MEK inhibitor continues to be efficacious in FAP.
Do you see a path forward in sporadic CRC, and why or why not?
Potentially, certainly that pathway is relevant in CRC.
I think it's a pretty crowded space.
And I think that
with the FAP program, we have the real opportunity to tackle an
unmet need there.
But certainly, the fact that these polyps will
eventually turn into colorectal cancer, it does give you the
hypothesis that this could work in sporadic CRC as well.
But not much more to share there.
Thank you. Here on the left.
Hi. Thanks. Excellent talk. Some of the questions I had already
answered, but I have one more.
My name is Itai Jacob from AstraZeneca.
I think
your brilliant operating system from biology to insight, from insight to
molecule, and from molecule to patient is amazing.
Wondering, have you been leveraging that to actually
train and build models? For example, the
model that you have, the
transcriptomics data foundation model, for example, and other models that you've
probably been building. So have you been leveraging that too
as part of the training strategy and model architectures that you've been
developing?
Yes. Again, I'm not an AI person. I know I said that we're all
bilingual, but I've only been here for a couple of months, so I'm going to need a
few more months to really become bilingual in AI.
I'm much more of a translational medicine subject matter
expert. But what I can say is that we're constantly trying to improve
each pieces of this platform. And like I said, the
translational gap, we're really trying to close that by using these
transcriptomics and foundational models that we're building.
So yes, Recursion in general, at a high level, is constantly trying to
innovate in order to do things better, to do things faster.
Hopefully that answered the question, but again, the whole team is here with me, so
please feel free to come find us after the talk.
It would be great to touch base on that more.
Sure.
I think that this is the frontier, and you guys are at the frontier, so I would
like to learn more about how you're actually leveraging all this end-to-end to
build those models.
Yeah. That would be great.
Thank you.
Thank you so much, Ita.
In the interest of time, perhaps you can ask the question to Tiru
after the session concludes.
So I apologize, but we need to get to the final talk.
Thank you so much, Tiru, for the excellent talk and for fielding so many questions.
Thank you.
Okay. Now I have the distinct pleasure of introducing George
Reis-Filho.
He's the Chief AI and Science Innovation at AstraZeneca,
and his talk is AI Transformation of Pharmaceutical
R&D.
Thank you so much. It's such a distinct pleasure to be here with you today and to
see so many familiar faces and so many colleagues, and actually so many frontier
AI people in the audience as well. I feel really humbled that all of
you are with us here today. So what I'd like to do
is to discuss with you how we are seeking to apply, really
intentionally, AI to transform every aspect of what we
do in R&D.
And we are a big pharmaceutical company. So how do we do it?
So these are my conflicts of interest from my distant past, but they remain current
anyhow.
So let's get started here. Where
this has all begun. I think
from our perspective, I would submit here that critical
developments in oncology research and also oncology
clinical development
actually mirrored technological developments over the last 30 years.
I think it's self-evident. If you stop for a second and you think about it, there
is a clear correlation, and it's causal.
It's not only a correlation. Actually, we are
moving, and we have moved from the idea of requiring
extremely well-curated, extremely harmonized
tabular data sets,
to actually using raw multimodal data.
Can you believe that in the space of what?
20 years.
And if you recall the big data thesis of
2017, 2018, we have moved such a long way.
It's quite incredible. Second, as Jacob alluded to in his
talk,
we are moving from that idea of handcrafted annotations, fully
supervised models,
to actually self-supervision,
extracting features, and utilizing the raw data
first principles.
And actually, we are able to derive many more insights by doing
that.
Not only that, we are going from
self-supervised learning
in a single modality, the unimodal foundation models, to
multimodal foundation models.
Not that we're quite there yet. We have not yet solved the problem
of the semantic layer across data modalities.
It's a problem for us
to solve together, I would submit.
In parallel with that, we have seen the birth and the growth
and the transformation brought about by agentic AI.
And no longer can we code tools. Actually, we can
perform relatively complex tasks in a
semi or completely autonomous manner now.
And we have moved into the space of coding agents now.
And as of last week, we've seen the
development of automated alignment
researchers.
Just think about that for a second. Automated alignment researchers.
So models can train models and get better performance without a human.
It's quite incredible.
And we are moving even further here,
that of going from agency
to delegated awareness for the agents.
Again, let's just stop here for a second. Let's think here.
Delegated awareness. So the agent understand the system
that we are actually confronting
and is able to reason what are the best
solutions, the most possible solutions for the problems we have.
So it is something that's happening. It's not science fiction.
It's happening today.
Can we again agree, all of us, that AI is no longer the future, it's
today?
Just for a second, can we just share that reality?
So if you accept that, then you understand that what our
premise was back then in 2025,
when actually
we reasoned that our
core thesis was this.
That AI is going to change every aspect of what we do in a big
pharmaceutical company, from accelerating drug discovery,
to transforming clinical development, to optimizing
clinical operations, to delivering journeys for patients that
are more seamless, more impactful, and more
meaningful.So with that
key thesis,
our premise was that
frontier AI models would outperform us
in reasoning and cognition tasks by the end of
2028. That was our premise,
that we'll get there before the end of 2028.
And why would we come to our leadership to articulate
that premise?
For three reasons, yeah. First, even last year,
even more now, if we take these AI models
offline and do an IQ test without any data leakage,
the IQ sits comfortably above 145.
It's a reality.
Second, if you look at the way these models are evolving
in relation to the
state-of-the-art benchmarks, they're just advancing so quickly.
First, they were increasing one order of magnitude every eight months.
They are now doubling every four months, and it's quite incredible.
Some models have reached a level of reason and cognition that the
developers are uncomfortable in releasing it in the wild.
And third,
that the length of tasks that can be autonomously performed
by agents
keeps advancing almost now on a weekly basis
to the point that coding, that was an incredibly
important skill that we need to have, and it was really hard.
You needed specialized knowledge.
Actually, it's available to all of us now.
It's not solved everything, and that's not what I'm saying, but it's available to
us, and we can iterate, we can build things, first principles
ourselves. Even if you don't know how to code with Julia to
optimize the hardware that you have,
you can do it now with some of the solutions available.
So with that in mind, what I'd like to focus on today
is that one of our
key strategies
relied upon this particular principle,
that by applying frontier AI models
to our key differentiator, our data,
we could transform clinical development in oncology.
That was
one of the key elements of our strategy. And what do I mean by that?
It's a lot of big words, yeah? But what do I mean by that?
AstraZeneca
has intentionally developed
a uniquely diverse portfolio
of therapeutic agents.
Five different classes of agents that you can see here on the right-hand side of
this color wheel. On the right-hand side, you can see five different
classes of agents that target the cancer cells directly.
ADCs, radioconjugates,
molecules that target DNA
damage response,
treatments that target disease drivers such as EGFR
mutations or ER signaling,
and also epigenomic alterations that locking of the cells into
a specifically state through epigenetics.
And we also have three different classes of therapeutic
agents that leverage the immune system to attack the cancer cells.
We have bispecifics in terms of the traditional IO
approaches. We have synthetic immunity in the form of immune
engagers and
cell therapy
for not only hematological diseases, but most
importantly for solid tumors as well.
So this
diversity enabled us to accrue translational
data over the last 15 years.
And what we're doing here is then we're using our
data to reinforce, fine-tune,
and augment frontier foundation models
that we source into our system.
And why do we use that strategy? Why are we not developing the foundation model
ourselves? Because in this space, in clinical development,
because the performance of our foundation model depends upon
the data diversity and volume. So the diversity across data
modalities and the diversity within a data modality.
For anyone to attain state-of-the-art
performance,
very large volumes of data with the right level of
diversity are essential.
So
we have decided to form partnerships to
bring these frontier domain-specific foundation models.
We created a partnership with Tempus and Pathos on one hand
to develop the largest ever multimodal oncology foundation model
for one reason. Because they had the best,
let's say,
multimodal clinical oncology data set available at that time,
with
EHR data, de-identified clinical notes, lab
tests, pathology images, pathology reports,
radiology reports. So we could use that to pre-train a model and
then reinforce, fine-tune, and augment with our data to derive new insights.
In the pathology space, we have also intentionally
benchmarked several models and created a partnership with Model AI that
led to the acquisition of the company earlier this year.
But the reason to bring these models is that the
insights that we generate
are to address four main tasks that we have as a
pharma company. First,
to reimagine patient selection through a multimodal
biomarker space. But here we are not trying to
do this, the most complex biomarker that you'll find, a small
population that respond. No, we are developing this on the basis of
maximum parsimony.So what is the smallest
set of parameters that would be required and sufficient for us to identify
the largest population that would objectively benefit from one of
our therapeutic agents alone or in combination?
Second, we are using this approach to
de-risk the transition from our Phase 1, Phase 2 studies to
Phase 3 studies.
Why? Because these models are able to generalize from
smaller sample sizes.
So the idea here is, okay, we don't want to be sitting with
40 patients' worth of data after Phase 1
and render that critical decision to move to a Phase 3, having that
level of uncertainty. If we can bring the insights from these models, we can make
better decisions. That's why I was asking the question about the
pursuit in that domain here.
The third,
how can we improve the probability of success of our Phase 3
studies?
And here, it's using another property of the foundation models as well.
That's to generalize from sparser data.
When we have a Phase 3 study, we don't have the depth of translational data
that we have from a Phase 1 or Phase 2.
So can we use those models to help us actually
render better decisions there as well?
And all of this, to be honest, is just to address our fourth point.
We'd like to develop the next generation of combination treatments
that will be transformational for patients.
I think it's a shared goal that all of us have to move the response rates
to a much higher level through the combination of therapies, and I
think we'll get there together.
At the end of the day, the ultimate goal is to transform patients'
lives and actually to advance our bold ambition in
oncology. That's to eliminate cancer as a cause of death.
I think it's a shared goal that all of us have here.
We realize that
that approach with the multi-modal foundation models coming from a clinical
perspective is one of the scales that we need to be aware of.
We also understand now that for us to get to the point that
I'm articulating here, we'll need to have the different scales
for the development of these domain-specific models,
from an atomic level
to the cellular level. And you hear a lot about virtual cells, and
I'd like us to define exactly what you mean when we say a virtual cell
being developed, and then from the patient level.
What we are learning as well as these are developed is that if
we take the embeddings from one scale and actually
refine and fine-tune them with the others from
another scale, we get even better insights.
So it's likely going to be an ensemble of models
that will allow us to get to the point where we need to be.
Yes, to derive those insights that actually will be transformational
for patients at the end of the day.
But we needed to start somewhere.
And I have to say that for us at AstraZeneca,
AI is really not the future, it's our reality. We're doing this.
We actually have been pursuing this for over a decade.
And one of the spaces where AI has had already an impact is
in computational pathology.
That idea that we can apply
artificial intelligence to computer vision of pathology images
actually started over 10 years ago.
First with deep learning,
convolutional neural networks applied to pathology images.
It was really exciting, but now we are getting to the point where we're seeing the
maturity of those solutions. A great example is our quantitative continuous
scoring system. That's basically a fully supervised
method where we use handcrafted annotations
to develop a model that can quantify the expression of targets at a
subcellular level, membrane, cytoplasm, and nucleus, in a
really quantitative way at the single-cell level.
We actually applied this first to the development of our
antibody-drug conjugates. The first was our antibody-drug
conjugate that targets Trop2.
In that space, immunochemical assay,
semi-quantification by pathologists, people like me
looking down a microscope, actually, we could not get to a
predictive biomarker.
With
the use of the quantitative continuous scoring system, we have now
demonstrated in the context of the tropionlongo one and tropionlongo
two that actually you can quantify the
expression of Trop2 on the cell surface in the cytoplasm,
derive what we call the normalized membrane ratio.
And that normalized membrane ratio is a surrogate for the
internalization of Trop2 as a target.
And that is a surrogate marker for the
response to our Trop2 target in ADC.
And actually, this is a great example of one of the types of biomarkers that
Jacob Cutter articulated in his talk, the type C, yeah, where we don't have an
equivalent by humans, and we are developing something new here,
something that cannot be quantified trivially with our approaches.
It's really hard then to develop and validate this.
You need validation in multiple datasets.
And actually, we're seeing the impact of this biomarker in the
next few months, few years with some of the prospective clinical
trials we're running at AstraZeneca
in the space of non-small cell,
non-squamous, non-AGE lung cancers.
The reality, however, is that for us to develop the solution that
received breakthrough device
designationBy the FDA. The first
ever to receive that designation in that context of
therapeutic prediction.
Actually, for us to develop that model, it took us...
I will let you guess. Imagine. How many hours of pathologists handcrafting
annotations to train the model
were required? Do you have an idea?
So I'll tell you, 40,000 hours of pathologists to develop one model
for one indication, one tumor type.
It's hard to scale, isn't it?
So we asked a question last year. What if
we brought a pathology
foundation model, highly capable,
to actually reduce or even replace the need
for handcrafted annotations for the development of the
model? Not the biomarker, the model to quantify a specific target.
And what we have witnessed is that you can go from 40,000 to
four and a half, even to zero. You just do the
benchmarks and the validation extensively.
It's quite incredible, isn't it? And it's extremely exciting because not
only for us, it's for the whole community.
This is a principle that if we have the most capable models, we can
start pressure testing, as long as we have very clear
evaluations and benchmarks.
Those are absolutely essential. And I'm going to reiterate again,
evaluations and benchmarks for everything that we do, and then extensive
validation of the biomarker once the biomarker is developed.
Where we're trying to get to now is to integrate
not only pathology, but multimodal data to help
inform patient selection strategies.
And for us to do that, we need to be able to connect
our data with the models to develop insights.
And for that, we are developing a whole agentic framework
to do
just that. That circuitry that's required and sufficient to
connect our data with the models in a way that we derive the embeddings from these
models. We can actually use them to derive the new hypothesis
and test them, and even generate new data to test the hypothesis.
But
for us to get there, I'm afraid to say that
it's going to be really, really hard to do this as an island, and I would not
suggest you to try this at home. Actually,
rather, what we need to do is to build an ecosystem of
partnerships whereby we can
actually bring together domain experts on one
hand
with people with extremely deep technical expertise,
the right orchestration on top, and then at the bottom, the right
infrastructure. And when I say infrastructure here,
it's your data infrastructure,
your compute,
all of the platforms that are required and sufficient to do that.
If one can bring all of those components together, then we
allow ourselves to ask the killer questions, the questions that actually really
matter for our patients.
So we have been building this ecosystem with
hyperscalers on one hand, with the frontier AI
companies,
with specialized AI companies. And we have several declared
partnerships with Tempus, with Pathos, with
Modelo, with
Immune AI, with Okin.
This is all happening.
And we also have partnerships with academics.
And I have to say that I've joined AstraZeneca, and I have
an incredible number of meetings with academics who are
actually developing the next generation of solutions, seeing
from around the corner, and we need to be there because
the pace of technological development is unprecedented.
And finally, that actually we started last year in September, we've brought
into these ecosystem partnerships patient advocacy groups.
Because developing the AI solutions without having the voice of the
patients is really, really hard. We need to understand what their needs are.
Not that they will constrain everything that we're doing, but having
that information help us
define what the path
should look like.
Another point that I would like to discuss with you is that we also approach
AI from a three-level perspective.
As I mentioned to you, in clinical development, if you think about the first layer,
the model layer, the
data of incredible volumes in adequate
diversity with the edge cases being adequately
represented is essential to develop the most capable models.
And I subscribe to the notion that we first need the most
capable models, then we can distill them down to find,
let's say, the smallest model possible that would provide the answers to
us, but we need to develop the most capable to begin with.
So we are actually there
developing these models through partnerships.
Where we actually are actively
engaged internally is in developing the solutions, the second layer,
utilizing those models to address specific questions.
For that, we are also building a really
complete stack of evaluations and benchmarks,
task-specific and end-to-end, to test how
performant these models are.
With those solutions,
then we have to develop the third layer, that's the applications.
What will touch the patients? What will actually get to the point of
informing decisions?
And we build this in-house using our datasets, but
we actually partner then with diagnostic companies, tech
bio companies, biotech companies, to get this to the patients.
We're not a diagnostic company. Our primary purpose here is to develop the
transformational treatments to our patients.So we are focused on our primary
purpose, and we do this through partnerships.
And I'm certain that by bringing all of this together, this
ecosystem of partnerships, and understanding the roles that we'll be playing,
we can get to the next wave of innovation.
One final point, one final thought that I'd like to share with you,
that I've come to realize
through experience and exposure, first and foremost.
I had not thought about it when I first started, that AI
in a pharma company of the size that we are
is not a technological challenge,
it's a challenge of people, process, and
culture.
And we need to help and enable our
team members to upskill and to transform themselves.
And we have to reimagine processes, first principles,
to deliver the solutions that actually will be
transformational for our patients and will allow us
to take many steps forward towards our bold ambition in
oncology. That is, to eliminate cancer as a cause of death.
With that, I'd like to thank you so much for your attention, and I'd happily take
any questions you might have. Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Kiro, I'm afraid that we are the only thing between them and
lunch.
So
let's just be aware of that.
Sounds good. While people are making their way to the microphone, I'll give you a
question that came up
online. Have you used BCMA and CD33
also as an ADC AI-induced biomarker?
I'm not in a position of commenting on specific solutions here today,
but we are
investigating all of the
different potential strategies for patient selection, not only in solid
tumors, but in heme as well. So
watch this space.
Sounds good. We'll take a question from the right-hand side.
Hi, George. Thank you for the very inspiring talk.
I embrace your enthusiasm, okay, but here
is a question. You mentioned a lot-- Sorry, Andrea Sotteriva, Computational
Biology, Human Technopole Milan. You know me.
You mentioned a lot foundation models, multimodal foundation
models. Now, in language and images, they work very well because their information
is very dense, okay? And we have
three, four orders of magnitude more data, okay, for
free from the internet. Now in biology, information
is sparse and data is scarce. And I
understand you propose, as you said, to
build up this data
infrastructure. But realistically, if you take off your AstraZeneca hat and you
keep your
research hat, as a scientist, as humanity, how do
we generate enough of this multimodal data in
biomedicine to really build models that are predictive?
Andrea, that's such a great question, and thank you so much for asking.
I think here,
if you think about petabytes in biology and clinical development,
a lot of it lies in the imaging space.
A lot of petabytes of data from radiology, from pathology
images.
What we've learnt over the last few years is that if apply
self-supervision to pathology images and radiology
images, if we solve feature extraction really well, we can derive
new insights.
Really new insights. And we are putting this to test, and actually, there is
a delta between just doing this with traditional
approaches, and if you use the embeddings to derive the new
insights. So this is one modality.
Then when you combine
pathology images with pathology reports into a vision language model, you
derive even more insights. And actually, you can use
then those models to help you understand the mechanistic
basis of some of the predictions made.
So it's building that stack.
We are also seeing in parallel many companies developing
extremely sophisticated strategies to
develop the data sets required for the training of these models.
So we are getting to that point where the data is going to
be sufficient for us to develop the first generation.
What is really important here is that it's not been solved
yet. Two problems have not been solved yet.
The development of the semantic layer across data modalities in a
truly multimodal way, and the second is that
the utilization of time as a first dimension
in the multimodal embeddings. These are two problems that we
hope to help solve over the next year.
Does that make sense?
Yeah. We can talk a bit more later, maybe, but thank you very much.
Thank you. We'll take a question from my left.
Hi, George. Thank you for the amazing talk.
My name is Arshad Ahmed. I'm with OneCell AI, and I'm a little
biased here, so just bear with me one second.
A lot of the discussion centered around, we hear Tempus a lot,
in terms of the data and
basically the foundation of the data.
If that's not solid, then everything else falls apart. Right?
So
I see three big limitations, and I would love to hear your thoughts on those.
One is these are done in archival samples, right?
These are not fresh biopsies.
They're done in bulk. These are not done in single-cell level.
And these are not done in longitudinal samples, right?
So these are done
at the baseline, but it's hard to get biopsies longitudinally unless you do a
ctDNA, but it's not single cells.What's your view
on the next generation of the Tempest database that'll drive the next
generation of foundation models, which will be fresh,
longitudinal, and single-cell level data, which also have
perturbations in it? Is anyone working on that, or is that a white
space? Is there even a need for it? What's your view on that?
Thank you so much for the question.
I had that slide with the atomic, cellular, and patient
level.
The patient level is what we could do today.
And actually, one important point is that
those longitudinal samples are like gold dust,
because if you can include them in the pre-training, it becomes
really more powerful.
Second, we need to bring the time dimension to that, and one can
start deriving that dimension
through the
de-identified clinical notes. Because there are so many time points, we may not
have the samples, but we can start understanding chronology and temporality.
Now, your final question, do we need to generate the single-cell
data with perturbations,
let's say, where we understand exactly which parameters
we changed,
and quantify before and after? Absolutely.
And I believe that many in this ecosystem are
directly involved in the generation of those data sets.
And they will actually bring the next generation of the
models.
We'll take another question from online.
What is your perspective on the black box nature of these AI tools
and their use in a regulatory-heavy environment?
That's such a great question, actually.
I'm not sure if that word black box is applicable anymore.
Because
actually, the level of system introspection that these models can
perform today is quite incredible.
The regulators are actually evolving with us.
Before, mechanistic and explainability was a condition that was
sine qua non, was mandatory. And as you could see in the
ESMO guidelines, the EBHI,
and
also in discussions with several
regulatory agencies,
the main requirement now is multiple
validation of the solutions derived.
If we have explainability, even better.
But what's essential is that we demonstrate the performance of
the particular AI solution in terms of clinical utility,
very clearly, with adequately powered data
sets, and done in a way that's scientifically rigorous.
That's what I would submit. But the partnership with the regulatory agencies now
is super exciting because they're prepared to iterate with us and to
think about the next wave of innovation.
I think we can have time for just one more question. We'll go to the right of me.
Hi. Thank you so much for the great talk.
My name is John Wu Kong from UC San Diego.
I had a really similar question from the question actually asked
by the online
audience, which is model interpretability.
And my two questions, one question
is how much validation would be needed?
For example, how many cohorts or how many number of samples in addition to the
training data set and the validation and benchmarking data set,
can we be sure that the model is
we think is going to be generalizable?
Generalizability is the question. Absolutely.
And the second question is, once you go beyond
unimodal foundation models and building a multimodal foundation
models, I would think that the interpretation will be much more harder
because you now have to investigate not only the
unimodal
model features, but you have to really understand how these
multimodal features interact with each other, which raises another layer of
complexity in terms of interpreting the model.
So I'm wondering, what's your thought on that?
So let's begin with the second question first.
Mm-hmm.
Let's imagine a narrowly fusion model where most of the
additional information derived is in the form of nonlinear correlations in
the latent space. How do you explain this, yeah?
And that's why the regulators are saying you need
extensive validation, because that we may not be able to
semantically translate into words.
But for us to get there, because then we are getting into the
territory of open-endedness, aren't we?
We don't know the answer to the question.
We're trying to derive a new question because our traditional train of thought
cannot get us there. Is that correct? Yeah.
If so, then we need evaluations and benchmarks for all
the sub-tasks and tasks as we progress.
And then we need validation in multiple data sets.
The magic number, I do not know. It's going to be
context-dependent and solution-dependent, and we'll need
interactions with the regulators so that they can articulate what would be
required and sufficient for us to satisfy the principle of
safety
for the patients, and that the AI is actually
performant enough and robust enough to be shipped clinically.
Got it. Thank you so much.
I think we're all set, and I
think we're going to have to move out of this room.
So we have to vacate the room.
First, I'd like to thank you so much for your attention.
I'd like to thank you so much for asking the
provocative questions and for pressure testing us, and for sitting
through this session that despite the logistic
disruptions that we faced,
Lufthansa did not help. We actually got the message across here,
and
I would like to thank you again for spending this Saturday with us.
Thank you.